a developing story here at 4 30 the body
of amari
nicholson found a few hours ago good
afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here
i'm christian cosas i'm kirsten joyce
this discovery was made at paradise and
twain the very same area where the
little boy was last seen one week ago
that's where joel mueller is live
outside the emerald suites with more on
what
unfolded throughout the day joe
after days of searching the body of
amari nicholson was found here at the
siegel suites
a little after one o'clock his body was
removed from this gate you see over here
between the building and the wall
and to give you an idea just how close
it is to the emerald suites where he was
last seen one week ago you can see the
sign there
it is just around the corner here from
paradise and twain now there's a
memorial just below that sign
people have been bringing by candles and
flowers throughout the day
a group of people could be seen outside
the seagull suites near near this
location where amari's body was removed
investigators found him between the
perimeter wall in the building people
were emotional watching this all unfold
he was last known to be alive last
wednesday near that emerald suites
location where his mother taylor
nicholson was living
her boyfriend terrell rhodes was
arrested in connection with his murder
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the seagull suites just
a few
hours ago this was all blocked off with
caution tape and there was
a crowd of people out here watching this
all happen many were emotional
many were crying some saying i love you
amari again there is a vigil planned for
six o'clock this evening just around the
corner at the emerald
suites many people who are here say they
do plan to attend that vigil we will
have
be covering that vigil as well so you
can stay with us here for the very
latest